[Música]
ucrania denuncia que las tropas rusas
están atacando los túneles de la
siderúrgica costales mariupol donde está
el último remanente militar de los
ucranianos esto mientras la onu intenta
de evacuar más civiles de la ciudad y
quien busca donaciones internacionales
para financiar la guerra
el presidente mexicano andrés manuel
lópez obrador se reunió con su homólogo
guatemalteco alejandro giammattei como
parte de su primera gira internacional
los mandatarios anunciaron programas
para atender la migración desde su
origen ampliamos con nuestro
corresponsal en centroamérica
alianza histórica de la izquierda
francesa los socialistas y la francia
insumisa sellaron una coalición para las
parlamentarias de junio así junto con
los verdes y los comunistas quieren
restarle escaños al partido del
presidente de manuel mayor colectivo que
se alió con el centro y cambio de nombre
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
mi nombre es maría clara calle y es un
placer saludarlos y comenzamos con la
actualidad del sureste ucraniano el
ministerio del interior de ese país
afirma que los rusos entraron a los
túneles subterráneos de la acería us
hostal en la ciudad de mariupol un
electricista les mostró el diseño de los
túneles a las tropas rusas y eso les
permitió asaltarlos según las
autoridades ucranianas todo esto
mientras la onu pib era el tercer
intento para evacuar a civiles además el
presidente volodymyr selenski lanzó una
plataforma llamada united turn y ford o
un y 224 en español esto para recaudar
donaciones adicionalmente en varsovia
recolectaron 6.500 millones de dólares
para ayudar aquí es
kiev sigue pidiendo ayuda y europa
responderá en la conferencia
internacional de donantes de varsovia el
jueves el presidente ucraniano volodymyr
selenski hizo una aparición virtual
pidiendo más asistencia económica 2 está
en finanzas de recursos necesitamos
suficientes recursos económicos para que
los hombres y las mujeres de ucrania
puedan estar provistos de los
suficientes recursos que necesiten
mientras la guerra continúa el estado
ucraniano como administrador de estos
cubrirá todas las necesidades urgentes
en defensa y ayuda humanitaria y
humanitaria por el momento ya han
surgido resultados inmediatos del
proceso elogiado por los líderes
europeos
en esta conferencia fuimos capaces de
reunir más de 6 mil millones de euros y
este dinero será distribuido para apoyar
a ucrania y todos aquellos que apoyan a
ucrania porque sabemos cuán doloroso y
costoso está siendo para la nación
ucraniana ruina
for you crying in nation entre los
países que aumentaron su asistencia se
incluyen finlandia república checa
croacia
quien amplió su ayuda anual a ucrania en
300 millones de euros para el presidente
del consejo europeo charles michel
podría ser la plataforma de lanzamiento
para una futura recuperación completa
queremos estar operativos y este
encuentro y la decisión que salga hoy en
mi opinión debe ser un punto de partida
para un plan marshall europeo para
ucrania
esto significa que ayudará a ucrania y
ayudaremos a la gente de ucrania
el encuentro llega cuando zelinski
intenta ganar tiempo en la esfera global
para facilitar la asistencia financiera
el jueves su gobierno también lanzó una
plataforma de crowdfunding global
llamada united twenty four todas las
donaciones serán transferidas al banco
de ucrania y asignadas a los ministerios
más importantes del país en la primera
visita de su gira internacional el
presidente mexicano andrés manuel lópez
obrador se reunió con su homólogo
guatemalteco alejandro giammattei los
mandatarios hablaron de programas para
frenar el flujo migratorio en
centroamérica el presidente mexicano
afirmó que sólo con cooperación
internacional
a poner fin al fenómeno migratorio
escuchemos a lópez obrador
vamos a seguir insistiendo
respetuosamente en la necesidad de la
colaboración
de eeuu
más allá del fenómeno migratorio estoy
convencido de que
este continente debe avanzar nuestra
américa toda américa hacia una
integración económica y comercial
sin exclusiones
al margen de diferencias ideológicas
vamos a esta ciudad de guatemala donde
está nuestro corresponsal y
centroamérica andrés suárez andrés un
placer saludarlo de nuevo y usted ha
reportado desde el palacio nacional
donde se encontraron los mandatarios
explíquenos que acordaron los
presidentes lópez obrador y giammatei
bueno maría clara lo más importante es
un acuerdo de desarrollo integral por el
cual el presidente guatemalteco
alejandro giammattei le agradeció al
presidente habla el presidente andrés
manuel lópez obrador porque ocurrirá a
partir de ahora mucha gestión con los
diferentes gobernadores en el caso de la
materia agradeció a amlo la gestión con
los gobernadores de los estados
mexicanos de la zona fronteriza del sur
de méxico con el norte de guatemala
habló por su parte dijo que méxico había
estado por muchos años rezagado en ser
un líder en la región en la región de
américa latina pero que ahora con su
gobierno
eso ya no no va a pasar y estos acuerdos
de desarrollo integral lo que sí
significan es emular las diferentes
políticas que méxico ha llevado a cabo
el interior de su país como por ejemplo
en las miles de becas que se han
entregado el programa sembrando vida en
el cual se ataca por ejemplo la
migración desde rne desde la raíz desde
las comunidades y esto significa que la
migración no sea
rosadas y no sea optativa como lo dijo
en sus palabras y al mismo tiempo le
reclamó a los eeuu y que seguirá
insistiendo los 4 mil millones de
dólares que se habían prometido desde la
administración trump y aunque dijo que
las comparaciones eran odiosas que no se
debería comparar criticó que hayan sido
ya desembolsados 30 mil millones de
dólares para la guerra de ucrania
mientras que para los países
centroamericanos aún no se ha gestionado
ese dinero así fue ella se ocurrió esta
declaración conjunta de amlo de
giammatei en el palacio nacional de la
cultura de guatemala y el siguiente paso
de esta gira por centroamérica será en
el salvador con el presidente nadie
bukele andrés y estaremos atentos a qué
pasa en el salvador muchas gracias por
su reporte
la izquierda francesa logró un pacto
histórico los socialistas se sumaron a
la coalición que lidera francia y sumisa
y en la que también están los
ecologistas y los comunistas aunque
tenían diferencias sobre la relación con
la unión europea finalmente finalmente
se aliaron para que de manuel marco no
quede con las mayorías en las elecciones
legislativas de junio
por su parte del partido oficialista
república en marcha se unió con los
centristas módem y oryzon en un intento
por no perder los comicios y también
cambiaron de nombre a penas en su
renacimiento
solo sonrisas entre los negociadores del
partido socialista por el acuerdo con
francia en su misa el histórico pacto es
un intento de impedir que el presidente
manuel marco obtenga la mayoría en el
parlamento pero el acuerdo podría
provocar la implosión de uno de los
partidos tradicionales de francia ante
las críticas de antiguos dirigentes
el secretario del partido lo defendió no
me he convertido repentinamente en
francia en su misa lo que pienso lo
seguiré pensando sería una completa
locura pasar de esto y pensar que porque
tenemos desacuerdos no podemos gobernar
juntos pienso exactamente lo contrario
según olivia fue esta unión es la única
forma de salvar el partido uno que lleva
casi una década en una espiral
descendente desde la victoria de
françois long en 2012 hasta el 17 % de
anne hidalgo sólo han pasado 10 años
hidalgo ha criticado el acuerdo pero ha
dicho que no quiere interponerse en su
camino para otras figuras del partido la
unión es impensable ni con solomont ni
su ex primer ministro bernat kushner
respaldan el acuerdo uno de los
principales puntos de fricción era
europa el partido socialista ha acordado
apartarse temporalmente de la de la
unión europea mientras que francia en su
misa dice estar dispuesta a desobedecer
las el acuerdo ofrece 70 escaños al
partido socialista con la esperanza de
ganar unos 30 los periodistas tunecinos
protestaron en contra de la creciente
represión a su labor durante el gobierno
del presidente de caixa y desde las
calles de la capital la homóloga túnez
denuncian que aunque las amenazas ya
existían se acentuaron desde que esa y
tomó el poder en 2021 de hecho la
organización reporteros sin fronteras
alertó en ese momento que el golpe de
estado afectaría a la libertad mediática
que había sido uno de los grandes logros
de la revolución de 2011 y justo esta
semana la ong afirmó que túnez cayó 21
posiciones en la clasificación mundial
de libertad de prensa y ahora está en el
puesto 94 entre las 180 naciones
y la casa blanca por primera vez en su
historia tendrá una secretaria de prensa
afroestadounidense
se trata de karim jean pierre quien a
partir del 13 de mayo reemplazará a jen
psaki desde que comenzó el mandato de
joe biden yampier se ha desempeñado como
subsecretaria de prensa además será la
primera secretaria abiertamente lesbiana
en servir en dicho cargo
y así terminamos las noticias en france
24 los invitamos a que sigan conectados
con nuestra programación
[Música]